been another difficult week for the
prime minister it feels like we're
saying that every week at the minute uh
it looks
almost impossible for the government to
get its brexit deal through
labour haven't committed to calling a
confidence motion in the government so
will the snp we think labour should
table a confidence motion and i said
last week
if it does so the smp will support that
i think it is possible that a confidence
motion right now
could succeed this is a government that
is weak and unstable and becoming more
weak and unstable with every day that
passes
but even if it didn't pass and succeed
at the first time
of asking there is another merit in
having a confidence
motion called just now because it would
help clarify labour's position
you know labour's position right now is
that it won't back a second eu
referendum
until it has tried and failed to trigger
a general election
but if it won't try to trigger a general
election then we're in this catch-22
position and it seems to me right now
that labour
is as much a barrier to making progress
on brexit as the tories are so we think
there should be
a confidence motion and we'll continue
to talk to
other opposition parties there should
also be
uh the bringing of the vote on the prime
minister's deal
this week the prime minister simply
can't be allowed to just
play for time and run the clock down we
don't have time to waste any more so we
need
clarity we need things to move on and
frankly it's time for
a new approach this is a pretense by the
prime minister that her deal
somehow can be salvaged and will get
some last minute miraculous change of
heart by the european union it's not
going to happen and the more time that's
wasted right now
at the worst for everybody potentially
so if you think there should be a
conference motion
why doesn't the s p call one well we
will continue to consider that
as an option but as you probably know
the snp could table emotion but the only
party that is guaranteed to have that
motion called for debate
in the house of commons and to have a
vote on it is the official opposition
party
so it makes we can't take the motion and
we
may well do that but we want to do more
than just have a gesture around this we
actually want to
bring this to a vote and therefore it
seems to me that labour doing
is the best in fact the only guaranteed
way of doing that and of course it
stands to reason i mean this is
a pretty obvious point i'm about to make
that without the support of the official
opposition party then clearly
that's not going to succeed so let me be
very clear the snp
will keep all options open and if labor
won't act then we are prepared
to act but it's labor that can bring a
motion that is guaranteed to be debated
and voted on and
i'm sure most people would agree that
that's the most sensible way to proceed
and
if it doesn't succeed and i don't think
we should assume it won't succeed given
the incompetence of this government then
at least it gets labor into a position
where they can take a decision on
whether or not they back a second eu
referendum because it seems
increasingly obvious to me that that's
the best way and perhaps the only way of
making progress and resolving this whole
sorry mace
okay well let's talk about the idea of a
second referendum because there is
lots of uh chatter about the possibility
of the second voter in westminster at
the minute with reports that some of
theresa may's allies are sort of
secretly preparing for one
um with the snp supporter i'm guessing
that you would and what should be on the
ballot paper
well romaine should be on the ballot
paper i mean i i've read
reports in the last few days that
theresa may might or
she might be forced by colleagues into
position where we should
she would propose a referendum with her
deal or no deal on the ballot paper i
mean i think
most people would take the view that
democratically that wouldn't be
an acceptable choice i i think there
should be a second referendum
that give people across the uk the
opportunity to decide given everything
that we now know
after the last two and a half years to
remain
in the eu and to answer your initial
question yes the snp would support that
if there was to be a second referendum
would there need to be some kind of
safeguard in place
to dictate what happens if scotland as
it did last time
voted in a different way to other parts
of the of the uk
the smp would propose that as we did the
last time we put forward
the proposal the last time that the uk
could only leave the eu
if all four nations of the uk voted for
that and that would have been a
recognition that
the uk is not a unitary state it's a
relationship of four
nations and you know if we cast our mind
back to the scottish independence
referendum we were told that it was a
relationship of equals so
the snp would certainly make those
proposals but you know
whatever the constitutional future of
scotland is and
as you know i hope and expect that will
be as an independent
country but it makes sense for scotland
to have the whole of the uk
within the european union so the most
important thing i think now
given the mess that has been created
over the last two and a half years
is that people all over the uk get the
opportunity to change their mind and in
a democracy
surely people have the right to change
their mind well let's talk about that
ability to change their mind if there
was a second referendum on brexit
do you think that there would have to be
a second referendum on scottish
independence as well
well look there is a difference between
the brexit vote and the scottish
independence
vote and you know for that reason i
don't think we're necessarily talking
precedence here if you cast your mind
back to 2014
there was a very detailed prospectus
that told people what they would be
voting for if they voted yes to
independence
the white paper on independence 800 plus
pages of it
set out all of the details set out some
of the compromises and trade-offs that
would be required
of course not everybody agreed with that
but nobody can deny that detail was
there
that is in stark contrast to what
happened
um in terms of the brexit vote where we
had that slogan
or to be much blunted about it that lie
on the side of a bus people didn't know
what they were voting for and now we
have the
situation where people are trying to
interpret what the brexit vote meant you
know theresa may
says oh it was a vote to curb
immigration or it was a vote for an
independent trade policy frankly
and there's no clarity on that
whatsoever and on the question of should
there be another vote on scottish
independence now
i'll set out my further views on that in
the new year once we get over
at this period of turmoil around brexit
but
the whole brexit process over the last
two and a half years has strengthened
the case
for scottish independence immeasurably
in my view not just because our vote
in 2016 was ignored not just because
scotland's voice has been cast aside
over these past
couple of years but if you look you look
at position of ireland an independent
member of the european union been shown
support and solidarity
by its colleagues in the eu contrast
that with devolved scotland completely
cast aside our interests
ignored and you know last week watching
all of these small
independent members of the eu having
more say over
what happens to the future of the uk and
scotland right now than scotland does
i think helps to make the case for being
in charge of our own destiny as a
country
okay i mean i think that some people who
support brexit would probably dispute
the idea that
um people didn't know what they were
voting for at that referendum but the
other thing that i'm quite keen to ask
you about as well
is why is it that you're you know
obviously a supporter for uh scottish
independence you you're
unhappy with scotland being dictated to
by westminster
but you're happy to be a member of the
eu you're keen to be member of the
single market
and the kind of rule taking that that
involves so
why is it different by you know the
relationship with brussels and that of
westminster
well i think that is frankly with the
greatest respect a really overly
simplistic argument the european union
is an organization made up of
independent countries nobody argues that
france or germany or ireland
are not independent countries they come
together pooling sovereignty
to help deal with and tackle some of the
big challenges that no country can do
alone in the modern world climate change
for example through the eu the
world's biggest single trading market
has been created and you know you only
have to look at ireland just now
ireland's not being dictated to
ireland in many ways is calling the
shots in the eu so the power of small
independent countries
in the eu is there for all to see right
now
um and as i said a moment ago that is in
sharp
contrast to the position of scotland
within the uk
where our interests are being cast aside
our voice has been ignored we face being
taken out of the eu and the single
market against our will now
an independent scotland will always have
the closest of relationships with the
other nations
of the united kingdom that much is
self-evident
but i think the case right now it
becomes all the more stronger for
scotland to
also have that close relationship with
our colleagues across the eu
um to be that internationalist
outward-looking country that continues
to play
a part in the world and doesn't have its
interest completely cast aside in the
way that's happening at the moment
um okay and then just finally and we
haven't got long on the interview and
but i wanted to ask you about
jean-claude juncker we were talking
about him earlier on the program with
rebecca long bailey
this week he ruffled a woman's hair he
joked about kissing the prime minister
i mean you may disagree with theresa may
on policy but do you think she's
suffering for a bit of
sexism i i did catch that last part of
your question i saw the
photograph of i saw the video footage of
jean-claude
juncker ruffling somebody's here i mean
i i think that looked pretty uh
distasteful i don't know the context of
of that but it wasn't
it wasn't the nicest video footage i've
ever seen